how you doing guys today we have a 2021
Dodge Ram 1500 and we're going to make a
key from
scratch by the way if you like my videos
I would recommend to subscribe so you
can see our daily videos I'm going to go
to immobilizer agree to the terms I'm
going to go to dodge I'm using by the
way the IM 100 or im508 by altel key
machine and I'm using the universal
altel remotes I'm going to go to
automatic selection and going to hit
okay I'm going to turn the hazard lights
on in order to wake up the computer and
we're going to get connected in a
[Music]
sec you want to make sure you have a
Wi-Fi connection for this uh password
reading now it tells me that I need the
uh star connector the special connector
that goes underneath the steering column
if you know don't know what it is look
on my videos and you will see how to
connect it we're going to uh go ahead
and approve it and now it's going to
look for the PIN code and it's going to
take between 1 and 10 minutes I'm going
to skip it and after that wait you're
going to see five digit then I'm going
to go to immobilizer smart system
because it's a push to
start I'm going to go to key learning
key learning and I'm going to hit okay
and he tells me to take all the original
keys out there is two in the memory and
we're going to register the next one he
tells me the password and he asked me to
verify
it and the next step is going to tell me
to push with with the proximity to the
ignition in for about a minute but
actually after like 30 seconds that's
going to register and then right after
it register it tells me to release it
release the push button and I'm going to
hit okay on the
machine and it's all done now we're
going to go and test it
out um it locks and unlocks starts the
car everything comes on there is three
keys in the memory um we testing the
lock and the unlock everything works the
way it should Universal autel highly
recommended don't forget to like And
subscribe if you have any questions
write in the comments below and I would
love to answer thank you very very much
for watching
[Music]